Netflix has become absolutely huge and
there's article after article about how
there revolutionising television and was
serious like house of cards and oranges
of the new black and everyone is binge
watching now which is where you can
watch an entire series in three days
instead of watching it every Sunday
night on HBO and that this is the future
of television and I thought up having u2
on it would be an interesting discussion
to talk about the movie industry and is
this the way that everything's gonna go
are I'm watching all this Netflix stuff
and I do it in the in the binge fashion
but is this where movies are gonna go
because that seems to be the next
logical step
they're obviously making a lot of money
with this they're getting huge buzz and
it's what people want right in their
home are we going to be all watching
movies on Netflix you know made for
Netflix movies I mean it's just a guess
but no because the movie going
experience that you know started in
little Nickelodeon's and then through
silent film like that's still a thing
and people going out leaving their homes
and going to an event together with
other people and you know going to
dinner or whatever get no hooker
whatever you do that's still going to be
yeah yeah that was I think TNT yeah the
so you know that that that that will
continue but what we are seeing is this
starting with The Sopranos in 1998 this
incredible television Renaissance where
I'm sure you recognize as as an actress
that the best writing there's I just
can't even tell you right Film Festival
and there were some I saw some great
great movie Alexander Payne's new movie
Nebraska sensational there's some great
films but the best writing is on
television now it just is and and and
the you know I the show that's on after
Breaking Bad is a show called Lowe
Rising Sun with a wonderful actor named
Mark Strong about Detroit homicide cops
and as TV shows go it's I don't know
it's good it's not great you know for my
initial read have seen two episodes I
like it I'll continue watching it it is
until I went to Telluride it was better
than the last eight movies I'd seen just
the it shot better it looks better the
characters are believable they're
credible identifiable and it's not
it's not a great show but it's ten times
better than than most movies and most
big-budget and I'm guessing it didn't
have a transformers 250 million dollar
budget which actually probably had a 400
million budget how do you feel that as
an actress that that the good stuff the
good writing and what would give you the
most sort of rewarding experience as an
artist is the television I've just read
recently like is something for Amazon
called transparent with so fantastic
like just them Amazon's doing the
Michael Connelly books Harry Bosch books
that are so great and that's you know
and I met and that those have been
talked about for a movie for years it
was we know fans would always debate who
should play the lead character the
detective in the la Hollywood Bureau and
now the notion that it's going to be on
Amazon and it's gonna be maybe 10
episodes and you can develop a month
sounds sounds thrilling I don't think
the creators are not getting a lot more
control you know I think they're they're
able to do a lot more of what they want
I would assume I don't know this is but
I would assume they're they've just got
more free reign to be creative people
and when you've got 10 episodes and
you're not terrified you're gonna be
pulled after episode 2 when the ratings
weren't there wasn't orange as the new
Black was renewed before season torches
yeah because it's going on you know
what's actually good which I feel like
used to be what you know the more
mainstream we mentioned James Woods and
James Woods and Jon Voight and Liev
Schreiber these are movie stars yeah and
these guys are doing ray Donovan on
Showtime and it's fantastic and they're
all three great in it and you know Tim
Olyphant was on the verge of being a
Jaya Jaya movie star he's like so good
looking at straight guys and and he did
and he's on he's on FX I'm justified and
patton oswalt kevin space right i mean
these are serious actors there's the
anti shame been going on television now
there's a Glenn Close so we were talking
about my sunglasses before I had on
damages that is it's hardly shame it's
it's it's a blessing it's now it's
there's a little cachet to it or
something like that isn't that crazy
like well I wouldn't do an ABC show do
you guys think we lose something by the
binge watching experience because I said
I do think there's something to be said
for the fact that when Game of Thrones
was on we all saw the red wedding
the exact same time and then everyone
could immediately jump on Twitter and go
crazy about it where now if you watch
this in three days then someone takes
two weeks that you do some of the shared
experience right becomes a race it's
like oh my god you did it in four hours
somehow you watched ten hours of
television I can't keep up with that I'm
about to say this but your life changes
when you have children and so it's less
binge watching so I get like so I I
don't think it's gonna go away and I
think it will still you know I don't
think Game of Thrones is suddenly you
know any future seasons gonna get
released all at once I think this is an
alternative way that will change things
somewhat but I think it's also like it
didn't why are we you know we have
somebody arbitrary things that we do
things TV shows come on once a week
because that's what we decided they
don't want to wait that we say you know
the list of the 10 best of the five best
like what's wrong with eight and what
would be wrong with releasing a show
Mondays and Thursdays for six weeks like
at some point someone will try something
different as a movie critic we know that
we're told like the late summer here in
August is where they put the summer
movies there weren't you know last no
now it's September they put the summer
movies that are expected to do well why
like people don't want to go in August
like they were into it in July but I
never I go to a movie in August and
January in February where movies get
thrown because why like cuz why you know
I want to go to have a good time on a
Wednesday in January like I think it's a
movie if it were good I just think
there's hey we think formulaic ly in
this country and and maybe that will
change too which would be interesting if
you could see a show twice a week and
mankiewicz trying to revolutionize the
way we think not just about movies but
many many things